hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure
malwaren und willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender auspackvideo heute bin
ich wieder als Wednesday verkleidet denn
wir packen den Wednesday Adventskalender
aus
UI toll ich konnte es gar nicht glauben
es gibt wirklich einen Wednesday
Adventskalender gewöhnt euch bitte nicht
daran dass ich jetzt in jedem
Adventskalender auspackt Video irgendwie
verkleidet bin letztes Mal hatte ich ja
den brautkalender ausgepackt da war ich
eine Braut und bei winstay kommt das
liegt auf der Hand da muss ich mich als
one stay verkleiden und als eigene
kleine Challenge habe ich mir jetzt
vorgenommen in diesem Video so
uninteressierte möglich zu sein und
nicht zu blinzeln
aber dieser Adventskalender ist von der
Marke Szene Replikator und kommen
vermutlich aus UK also Großbritannien
und kostet 34 €, 90 € und somit können
wir auch wirklich sagen es gibt von
allem mittlerweile einen Adventskalender
finde diesen Kalender vom Designer
richtig schön und ich finde der ist gut
verarbeitet zumindest von außen doch
bevor das Video startet muss ich einmal
sagen dieses Video ist gesponsert was
passiert mit mir
[Musik]
sorry ich hatte gerade eine Vision dass
dieses Video von nordvpn gesponsert ist
Leute Ich sage euch wie es ist die
meisten Kalender findet man nur noch
online und jedes Jahr opfere ich meine
Daten und bestelle über 20 Kalender aber
ganz ehrlich muss das jeder wissen mit
nordvpn ist dieses Jahr mein
Internetverbindung verschlüsselt und
abgesichert wenn so richtig sicher fühl
ich mich nicht immer in Zeiten von
hacking und perfektionierten
fishing-mails bei nordvpn ist der
bedrohungsschutz mit dabei und kostenlos
sehr schön meine Geräte von bösartigen
links und virenen Download Dateien ab
nordvpn sorgt dafür dass alle meine
online Aktivitäten mit den über 500 VPN
Servern privat sicher und anonym bleiben
das ganze geht denkbar einfach mit einem
Klick über die App wobei ich alle meine
Geräte mit nordvpnvieren oder
schädlichen Websites und und und
schützen kann und falls es mal
langweilig werden sollte in never kann
ich ganz einfach auf alle meine
Streaming Plattform zugreifen oder
allgemein auf Entertainment was mir
sonst nicht zur Verfügung steht schaut
einfach in der Videobeschreibung vorbei
und gönnt euch mit meinem Link einen
ordentlichen Rabatt bei nordvpn und ein
unbezahlbares sorgenfreies suche
Erlebnis ich glaube das war's ich muss
wieder zurück
ich nehme das mit der Qualität dieses
Kalenders zurück so öffnet sich das
Türchen ich kann es nicht weiter durch
den mit dieser Zeit wir machen jetzt das
erste Türchen auf und das funktioniert
schon mal ganz furchtbar also der
Kalender öffnet sich überall nur nicht
an der Schnittstelle wo es vorher
gesehen ist habe ich jetzt schon was
kaputt gemacht was ist das für ein
Papier wow das hatte ich ja schon mal
toll geöffnet ich mein gut der letzte
Kalender hat 70 € gekostet dieser kostet
34 90 und wir haben mehrere Türchen in
Türchen Nummer eins befindet sich
ah
ja okay ein Wednesday Christmas tree
Anhänger die Schnur hätte ein bisschen
größer sein können aber ansonsten ja es
ist natürlich hier die billigste Ware
aber es ist
gut es ist Weihnachten und zwei Sachen
die Hand in Hand funktioniert
ich hoffe das war nur ein schlechter
Start und die anderen Türchen lassen
sich mega gut öffnen
nee das ist ja kacke also so schlecht
hat sich noch nie Kalender öffnen lassen
seht ihr das in all den Jahren habe ich
das noch nicht erlebt das ist so ein
unbefriedigendes Gefühl seht ihr das
ist das kacke
es hat ein bisschen gedauert aber wir
haben unseren Nevermore Kugelschreiber
ein süßer Fanartikel zu winsday oh der
schreibt richtig gut
er schreibt richtig satt wenn es halt
jetzt nicht die höchste Qualität ne das
ist jetzt hier aber schon cooler Stift
ich kann es nicht glauben dass es
draußen 30 Grad hat und ich hier mit
einem
strickwolpoli Sitze okay Türchen Nummer
drei lässt sich jetzt mega gut öffnen
mein Gott ist das
unbefriedigend
nicht in Türchen Nummer 3 befindet sich
nicht das ist bestimmt durchgerutscht ja
von außen wirkte der Kalender wirklich
sehr hochwertig auch ein toller
hochwertiger Druck und so aber das hier
ist gerade wieder einfach nur eine
absolute weiter mit Türchen Nummer 4
Nummer 4
das macht doch schon wieder keinen Spaß
was ist denn das Türchen Nummer fünf
Türchen Nummer fünf ist leer oh mein
Gott das hatten wir echt noch nie
gegen Bullshit kommen wir zum sechsten
Türchen Nikolaus was erwartet uns da
[Applaus]
und ich weiß was wir alle bis jetzt
dachten ja das ist halt leer weil es
runtergerutscht ist das ist unten kann
ich eigentlich so Leute dann auch
verklagen vier leere Türchen hatten wir
gerade in einer Reihe Nummer 7
Vanessa du machst den Inhalt kaputt ist
oh hier ist Inhalt den Türchen Nummer 7
das kann sein dass ich das gerade
gewesen bin nein doch
Socken ja Socken ist so ein Standard
Dinge im Adventskalender ne das macht
man nichts weiter und es sind ja so
Fanartikel zu Weihnachten Türchen Nummer
acht
[Musik]
ist das bloß lustig guck mal hahaha das
ist schon wieder leer wie cool cool
von allen Kalender
Türchen Nummer 9
was wenn das mal bei der Befüllung ein
Türchen nicht reingemacht wird okay das
ist scheiße aber es passiert wir sind
bei Türchen Nummer 9 und ich habe drei
Artikel 10
schon 11
was ist das denn bitte für ein scam
oh mein Gott ist das iconic dieser
Artikel gefällt mir echt weil ich mir
den hier gerade fürs video
gestellt habe
schön
aussieht wie Butterfly Messer habe ich
noch nie gesehen
14 14
mein Gott das ist geil ist das geil
16 17
wir müssen dieses Projekt hier an dieser
Stelle abbrechen das hat keinen Sinn
24 der stinkt nach Plastik
in der 24 oh mein Gott und hier hat sich
das verklebt mit dem Ding oh mein Gott
in der 23 ist natürlich guckt euch das
an das ist so zugeschweißt
und das einfach nichts drin in der 19
war aber noch was drin ne Tischdecke und
noch ein Produkt in der
22 ein Magnet okay zehn wir mal die
Artikel also wir hatten 24 Türchen 1 2 3
4 5 6
ich wurde gescammt in 24 Türchen waren
sieben Artikel drin ich kann es nicht
glauben hier seht ihr was drin sein
sollte ein paper clip gefallen
Magnet Bookmark dicker
Mädel Bookmark Patch Coaster
paperdorfhänger
bouncy Boy memoped ich sag mal so wenn
diese Sachen die da drauf sind auch so
drin gewesen wäre dann Werder sind 34,90
€ Adventskalender das ist halt so ein
bisschen rum aber wenn man jetzt wenn's
day Fan ist dann ist es auch Rammstein
man ganz gut verwenden kann und viele
Sachen ist ja auch dann für die jüngere
Generation bestimmt ganz interessant wie
zum Beispiel ein Radiergummi oder eine
mit einem Sack drauf oder ein popsocket
Wednesday popsocket die größte Frage für
mich ist einfach nur ja was mache ich
denn jetzt kann ich den so
zurückschicken kommen wir erstmal zu
meinem Fazit dieses Adventskalenders
also der sieht ganz toll aus und ich
finde die Artikel die da waren teilweise
echt toll zum Beispiel dieser Stift und
es ist ein bisschen komisch dass da nur
sieben Türchen befüllt wurden bei 24
insgesamt und ansonsten ist dieser
Kalender der größtes Game und ich kann
nicht mein schlechtes Wort verlieren
weil ich das Gefühl habe die haben ja
kann ich mal sauer sein weil es so
absurd ist das übersteigt die
absolidität die wir in diesem Format
jemals hatten oh mein gott stellt euch
mal vor ihre Schwester Cousine keine
Ahnung Onkel wer auch immer ist totaler
winstay Fan und dann denkt ihr euch ich
schenke der Person einen Winston
Adventskalender die sich freuen und dann
wird er einfach in fast jedem Tag nichts
drin sein das muss so deprimierend sein
so sieht's aus wir sehen uns beim
nächsten Video wieder bis dann
[Musik]